per gli archeologi del mondo che avete
aperto che subito perché sapete che io
ho insegnato a piero angela tutto quello
che sta ragazzi oggi siamo tornati su
ciò che esser che non è una puntata di
superquark ma è un video di fa vj strano
forse l'unico video di famiglia e dove
si può imparare qualcosa perché su tutti
gli altri si regredisce jorgensen per
chi non lo conoscesse questo sito che si
teletrasporta nel mezzo di un posto
famoso tipo questo chiosco chi non lo
conosce famosissimo chiosco e tu devi
indovinare in che parte del mondo 6
perché faccio la mappa del mondo di
schiacciare dove pensi che sia il luogo
chiosco di gesù dove si mangia un sacco
non era questo posso commodore a questa
roba qua fatemi vedere la casa bianca
non era a casa mia è la casa bianca nel
medioevo che solo nardò di caprio e
leonardo di caprio censurato so tizio
guanto annoiata la gente quanto è pronto
sto monumento alla milioni nominare che
cos'è sta roba subito ci penso io faccio
io faccio dove dovrebbe essere perché la
gente si fa le foto in pose molto sexy
madonna la mia cultura è affetta addio
che in america ne sono sicuro però non
mi non so tipo washington se non sbaglio
washington dove cazzo sta voci ecco la
cosa che non ho la più pallida idea di
dove sia sta roba aiutatemi vi supplico
gesù cristo e questo e questo sì lo so
io
[ __ ] era la manovra fiore quanti
washington ci sono aveva azzeccato che
da washington
provo scinto nella capitale non lo stato
li mortacci volta mi piace ci sono un
miliardo di nomi nel mondo ma
sceglietevi diversi si chiama washington
uno stato la città chiamatela pippo no a
una chiamata a washington
next round ha finalmente le piramidi
egizie con quale qualità di immagine me
lo stai dicendo sito solo perché sono
acculturata tela indovino anche se c'è
poca qualità perché sono una persona
troppo acculturata io qui
ah già l'arena di per sé c'è la bassa
qualità hanno scambiato per il colosseo
ci sono dei problemi
piero angela tecce da chi stai da
imparare o di marwa mihara galan è la
doll skull maccarone censurata la gente
perché non avete censurato le persone e
sto povero cristo qui che sta dando dei
soldi a all'imperatore che poiché sta
dando uno smartphone
l'imperatore michiara il velo che ci
sono stato mille volte fanno fatto a
scambiarla brixia non lo so e lo so lo
so che sei incazzato era stato negato a
zio prossima ditemi che l'ho tagliato
asta parte del video non l'avete vista
la buonissima vecchia america questa
dovrebbe essere la sveglia è descritto
mite las vegas
non so dormite la mappa di gta è uguale
guardo la di san andrea fabulous las
vegas forse giusto porca vacca radu
metri più avanti avesti cazzi next round
il mio sgabuzzino
adesso cos'è qui in america del nord
porca vacca cielo vicinissimo che era
proprio chiaro che era la grecia che
sfiga che non azzeccato next round qua è
che poi grecia è anch'esso nomi fatti
due volte e più forza
c'è una volta si cavasin stronzo ma
ricordavo così buia fraga maledizione
questa la sua offerta perché ma
citofonato guarda guarda questo
purtroppo questo è giusto vieni 4 siamo
i gay
eccoci qua perfetto quando c'è questo
posto che non ho capito che cos'è
vivibile due errori che sei bravo e
ridursi il mio giorno non si voleva in
francia fra entra così a caso sì sì a
cap questi sono palesemente francese e
francia francia doppia francia dove essi
come francia parigi 6 giu stoner
invece ti giuro in francia però
raikkonen repulsivo gravità di ore a
queste cannato come canada new york
questa gruppo essere guardata guarda che
ho ragione io
però però 150 km poter andare nel cibo
tenerezza navile apprezzabile ma questo
queste fantastiche sembrano spagnoli che
si guardano si molto molto spagnoli
questo luogo di cazzato a prescindere
che sia si stava annoiando bruttissima
capisce non riesco a vedere il video di
famiglie dove barcellona aiuto grazie e
si è palesemente false ma ho capito va
milano milano perfetto aver sbagliato
next round sattolo sto frullatore no no
avevo detto e fatto che non è fatto così
seattle si atto il matador che se
esistano stavano scambiando la droga era
il tipo di google li ha beccati in pieno
seattle facciamo queste space nino tondo
insomma space nemica se il fenomeno ma
se troppo bravo guarda cercherà la
rotonda vari spot vigevano vecchio di un
gatto preciso così ma invecchiando
preciso così 10 metri ora che abbiamo
tra che lo becco così preciso che si
vede la mano del tipo è fatto che questa
italiano in modo così ma figurati
cappelli agosto ma questa è una palla e
una palla da bowling senza alleli cocina
cima
la nonnina cimarosa cina nei ds secco a
casa e qui più a destra e palesemente
qui è mexes però mi ha dato cinque punti
vuol dire che quel 65 punti era la
distanza minima per prendere il
punteggio già pensate che lascia la
scena con giornate sembra bello con il
latte sembra pelle poi prima che della
gara che lo metterei mai bello che
sfamarsi bella panoramica già una
polizia 60 gente potrebbe essere islanda
in questo momento convincono questi
fatti se i massimi esperti di bio bio le
hawaii che vuoi
no io sono scelte qatar air e islanda
davvero dove era stato ormai a picchiare
altra parte della figura di azioni
ma cos'è sta roba qua e là santino e
vabbè dal giappone sulle donne o
giappone su dove però con ma è o il
mario con l'ago dichiara bellissimo caso
è supposto vado subito facciamo non sa
dove cede il perno del mare lago questo
non e vedrai tana ma cosa mira chi sa va
beh vuol dire che sono di green chi sono
sono tutte boh
olga sulla sua prima è una cosa per il
culo da se hai sbagliato a g ma comunque
verso le isole sono tutte visione della
minkia tutte anche questa china tang era
blog posto è lì si chiama troppo bello
thailandia
non fa che questa gli slayer yahoo
scommetti quasi non ci andiamo sempre
vicini nero dell'atlante delle figlie
filippina cronica incendiate sempre
perché quella era quella sotto quella di
prima allora sotto la cima è questo a
porca vacca questa notte un rullo questo
alberobello puglia puglia dove eccolo
albero dove stanno per dare scossoni io
io io io sono sempre alla disperazione
ma non capite ma con una che linea retta
più ce li meritiamo lo azzeccato ai
consumi e parallele parallelo al chi
utilizza il tasso era batka ramses senze
velario se viveva
ragazzi io ringrazio il mio socio che
senza di lui sarei a 12.000 chilometri
di distanza ma va bene così come viene
sia piaciuto spero abbiate imparato
molte cose sulla geografia cosa molto
importante al giorno d'oggi guardate
questo video se volete istruirmi di più
poi se volete vi piaceranno di piazza
che ha preso chiaramente tutti i test
non sono previsti altri ci vediamo
persone dai ragazzi
[Musica]